hey everybody how's it going so there's
a new Doctor Who trailer so this is
gonna be a breakdown to that but the
really big news is that River Song is
confirmed to be coming back to the
Doctor Who Christmas special this year
Moffat said that they're actually
starting to film it this month they're
filming it during September if you're
brand new to Doctor Who you have no idea
who River Song is and why everybody
won't shut up about her I'm gonna do
some of my favorite River Song moments
at the end of this but the big stuff
first Doctor Who series 9 episode 1 The
Magician's apprentice that's coming back
in two weeks
Saturday September 19th the tease that
the trailer is giving us is that there's
going to be a Missy Clara team-up it
kind of looks like them as well as some
bad people are trying to track the
doctor down this alien here looks new he
he doesn't look like something from
classic OOP but if you any of you guys
have seen anything close to this let me
know in the comments
series 9 seems like it's gonna be
creature heavy and just in general most
of them seem like they're gonna be new
characters so that's actually pretty
exciting just a lot more stuff to
cosplay as speaking of which I think I
mentioned this in my last trailer video
these do look a little bit like the
tattoos that the Sibylline sisterhood
had during fires of Pompeii and we know
they're gonna be revisiting that episode
sometime during series 9 it might not be
this episode but this might have
something to do with that so Missy says
in the episode that she has the last
will and testament of the doctor it
looks a little bit like a giant pocket
watch but she calls it a confession dial
that makes it sound like when they
turned the dial it's gonna be pointing
them in different directions what's
really got me excited here is this Dalek
looking city this looks like the Dalek
city from Doctor Who season 1 and when I
say season 1 like if you're not familiar
series 1 is from new who from like the
2005 reboot season 1 is like the very
first ever season of Doctor Who so the
confession dial might end up sending
Clara and Missy to Skaro the doctor here
looks like he's playing some sort of
game like he's been hiding out like
that's why he's wearing sunglasses and
he's super dressed down this is actually
this is a better image of his costume
the doctor in a ratty t-shirt like he's
been sleeping on the street or something
this looks a little bit like series 6
whenever he was playing that chess game
trying to get information about the
silence if you remember a lot of that
was built around the mystery of the
first question but they kind of already
wrapped that up that was intended to be
a code that would let the Time Lords
know that it was okay to bring Gallifrey
out of the pocket universe so I don't
think that you know whatever it is that
kept
holidays running from in this first
episode it is the first question I think
it's something completely different
usually whenever they tease things like
that that's people people like reach way
back into classic ooh like it's you know
somebody that gets lost like a lot of
people wanting Maisie Williams to be
Susan or another really old character I
think for the most part most of the
stuff that they do during series 9 is
gonna be relatively new like a lot of
new characters the old stuff that we see
from classic ooh will be like like
visual things like will visits carro
beat us can let me know like how do you
feel about the idea of a Missy Clara
team-up to try and track the doctor down
like to try and execute his last will
and testament it is a two-part episode
the second part is called the witch's
familiar so that I think that's a
reference to Clara and Missy
she's both the magician that like the
doctors apprentice and the witches
Missy's familiar the funny thing about
witches and familiars is that familiars
are usually more like pets really you
can think about Morse companions but
usually you know it's like you see a
witch and she has a cat and that is her
familiar so I think it's kind of funny
maybe that's how Missy will think of
Clara she'll think of her as like a pet
Michelle Gomez was a ton of fun at Comic
Con I'm really happy that series 9
features her heavily I don't know how
many episodes she's gonna be in but I
know she's a series regular she might be
the doctors greatest villain but I don't
think that she will be the main villain
of series 9 she'll still do very evil
things but I do think that there will be
a more vicious villain like Anwar you
know stabby villain for the doctor to
try and face you guys can let me know do
you think that Missy like even if she's
helping the doctor most of the season
will be the main villain of series 9 or
they'll be like somebody else that's
even worse usually what you see in
Doctor Who is there's a couple different
types of antagonists you have people
like like a person human-shaped
antagonists like the master you have
cosmic villains like the devil or like a
big you know universe collapsing problem
to solve and then you have the friends
as antagonists like when the doctor and
Clara are fighting or when the doctor is
fighting the Time Lords like when he
doesn't like some decision they make and
he has to go up against them usually it
ends up being a face like there's like a
face that you could put on the villain
just because that's really satisfying
for audiences speaking of which River
Song really friendly antagonists a lot
of times when she made really funny
jokes about being with the doctor like
being with him romantically it was older
versions
the doctor which is why everyone
wondered if she was coming back for a
Capaldi's run there have been 14 proper
episodes that she's been in but she's
done a lot of web cast like a lot of
like really small expanded stuff the
vast majority of those were Matt Smith
episodes but she did debut during David
Tennant's run you know silence in the
library force to the Dead which are - my
favorite River Song episodes I think
after that in no particular order
my favorite River episodes are The
Impossible Astronaut and day of the moon
that was the two-part series 6 premiere
let's kill Hitler also a series 6
episode that was actually the origin of
the Alex Kingston incarnation for those
of you that don't know River Song
regenerates like a Time Lord but she's
not a member of their race Angels Take
Manhattan also a really good Doctor Who
episode overall but not the best River
episode of my mind it made you cry
because it was a finale like it was the
end of Amy Pond and Rory the rest of her
appearances are pretty solid but like
those those episodes that I mentioned
are just the ones that stand out in my
mind Alex Kingston is a lot like John
Barrowman two guest actors that don't
show up all the time but are amazing in
the episodes that they're in and for
those that are wondering even though
John Barrowman is on arrow right now
like he's on he's on that show which
Alex Kingston has also been on - there's
been a lot of Doctor Who actors that
have gone on like arrow in the flash but
he did say that he would totally come
back to Doctor Who if Moffat ever asked
him to come back but he said that he
doesn't think that it's gonna happen in
case you don't know I do a weekly Doctor
Who giveaway whenever we get new
episodes so all you have to do to enter
that is be a subscriber and leave a
comment on this video or like whenever I
post Doctor Who videos pretty much
congratulations to the winner of my last
Doctor Who giveaway drew Haig you win a
$20 Amazon gift card just be sure to
message me on the back of my channel so
and get your contact info what will
happen is is I'll just announced the
winner from this week's giveaway
whenever I post my next Doctor Who video
as we get closer I'll start doing more
bonus videos if there are any requests
that you guys want like any specific
videos just let me know in the comments
I think what I'll do next is rank all my
favorite River Song episodes just
because it's such a huge deal that she's
coming back just in case you guys
haven't seen in a while you can click
here to watch the last trailer for
Doctor Who the Maisie Williams trailer
heavy on Maisie Williams and you can
click here for all the other trailers
that I've been posting the last couple
days there's been arrow season for
agents of shield season 3 all kinds of
stuff thank you so much watching
everybody let's high five I'll see you
guys tomorrow
you